Bienvenue sur le tournage du déménagement.
Et c'est parti !
Viens ! Je vais te montrer déjà un petit peu le décor...
C'est un faux déménagement
Bien évidemment,
les cartons sont extrêmement légers.
C'est lourd !
Le canapé par contre il est vraiment très lourd.
Ça fait a peu près une heure et demi
qu'on porte ce canapé.
J'aurais dû appeler le court-métrage :
"Les mecs qui se rencontrent avec l'intermédiaire des déménageurs"
On va devoir porter un frigo extrêmement lourd.
Quelle est l'histoire du déménagement ?
C'est deux personnages qui, à la suite d'un bug,
ils ne se connaissent pas mais pourtant ils vont faire un déménagement ensemble.
Nous avons le personnage de Yacine qui est plutôt rangé dans sa vie professionnelle.
C'est le genre de gars qui est tellement sage qu'il ose
pas dire non à son boss.
Là, on tourne la scène d'introduction où on voit la
soumission de Yasine envers le boss.
Le patron que tout le monde à toujours détesté.
Qu'on a pas envie d'avoir. C'est assez jouissif de jouer ça.
Et nous avons ensuite le personnage de Max
que j'incarne, qui lui a réussi un petit peu
à se lancer mais la réalité
c'est qu'il a plus de thunes.
C'est tout petit.
Ça me rappelle vachement moi à mes débuts quand
j'ai vraiment arrêté de travailler et que j'ai fait que des vidéos sur internet.
Est-ce que ça va marcher ?
Ah ah ah !
Est-ce que ça va durer ?
Ce qui est intéressant dans le film
C'est que tu tranches jamais.
Tu tranches pas la question. C'est 2 personnages qui ont besoin
- Ouais
un peu de l'un et de l'autre pour se motiver
sans tout remettre en question.
C'est la séquence émotion.
Ce petit comédien, qui mesure 1m92, c'est Sliman Baptiste.
On forme le duo de ce court-métrage.
Je suis, depuis longtemps, ses ébats audiovisuel sur internet.
Mais t'es beaucoup trop grand. Ça je suis obligé de le dire devant la caméra.
T'es trop grand.
Mais comme je sais jouer les jambes écartés, ça règle le problème.
- Ah si !
On fait l'affiche "Kev Gad tout est possible"
Ooohhhh !
Tu vois peut-être pas mais il pleut.
Ça ne fonctionne pas.
La plus grosse variable, c'est la météo.
Qu'on soit avec Spielberg ou avec Cyprien
on est comme même tributaires des nuages.
Voilà, on va attendre.
C'est l'heure où il y a le plus de bruit, le plus de mouvement, le plus de voitures.
On est dans des conditions parfaites pour tourner là.
Ouais, moi je suis à la compta et toi ça fait combien de temps que t'es dans la boite ?
Bonne journée.
Cette vidéo est dédicacée à tous les jeunes qui croient qu'on s'amuse sur un tournage de Cyprien.
Et grâce à moi, il fait du tandem pour la première fois.
On a une réunion salle 8.
Là, on va filmer une petite soirée qui se passe à la fin du film.
Ça se passe dans le nouvel appartement de Max
et du coup on a des chips.
- Qu'on a pas le droit de manger.
- Qu'on a pas le droit de manger parce que sinon c'est pas raccord.
C'est la dernière séquence où en fait le personnage de Max
met en ligne son jeu.
Pour moi c'est important et ce qui est bien, c'est qu'on voit un peu ces nouveaux amis.
Du coup le personnage de Yacine, et on comprend qu'ils ont gardé contact.
Plus qu'un clic et je vais sur Youporn.
Il fait froid quand on a des trous comme ça dans les jambes.
C'est chiant.
Bonne idée !... Brillante idée !
Dans ce documentaire, regarder le roumain dans sa mue.
Fin de journée. (x3)
Merci à l'inauguration.
C'est la fin du tournage du déménagement.
C'est une journée très très longue.
Ouais, c'était vachement bien.
C'était vraiment chouette. L'équipe était mortelle.
Je suis très content de collaborer avec les Parasites qui ont réalisé ce court-métrage.
On leur a parlé du script. Ça leur a plu.
A la recherche du Parasite.
C'est un modèle peu assistant sur ce petit court-métrage.
Nous avons un deuxième modèle. C'est un Parasite réalisateur.
En le trouvant, on est très content.
Non...ah et bah voilà.
C'est un parasite de type comédien.
Je viens de m'incruster à un des personnages des parasites dans le film de Cyprien
ni vu ni connu.
Je vous invite à aller regarder "Symptôme d'amour"
Merci à Slim qui à incarné du coup Yacine
et je suis très content d'avoir partagé ça avec lui.
Merci à Fanta d'avoir sponsorisé ce making-of.
Merci à vous de l'avoir regardé. J'espère que le court-métrage vous a plu.
N'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce vert comme dise tous les youtubers.
C'est un pouce bleu ? Voilà voilà. et Guillaume qui me fout la honte. Bravo !
A très vite sur YouTube, n'est ce pas ?